while definitely I've noticed a lot of
farmers around here are worried about
where they're gonna get their water this
year we're gonna cut back on water as
much as we can but it's not really
affecting us all as much as it is
affecting other people we use the pond
as our rain catchment system and then we
have a solar pump that is hooked up to
the pond
the solar pump all nice sunny days runs
water all the way down around and in
lines that we put up to the top of the
property or where we have storage tanks
it won't pump on rainy days but that's a
nice thing on rainy days we're able to
shut the irrigation off and so we won't
need it because we run on terraced
farming here everything is gravity fed
and it's all run on battery timers so we
have no fossil fuels going into our
water distribution system whatsoever
since we put that in luckily it has
ultimately the drought has unaffected
how many crops were able to grow because
the fact that we can irrigate from that
pond
so sativa in the most part is energetic
uplifting you for it you smoke this you
can use your peak in ten minutes the
indica full-body effect from